an isotope contains 16 protons 18
electrons and 16 neutrons what is the
identity of the isotope and i encourage
you to pause the video and see if you
can figure it out and i'll give you a
hint you might want to use this periodic
table here
all right so i'm assuming you've had a
go at it
so
an element is defined by the number of
protons it has so if someone tells you
the number of protons you should be able
to look at a periodic table and figure
out what element they are talking about
so because it is 16 protons well we can
go right over here to the atomic number
what has 16 protons well anything that
has 16 protons by definition is going to
be sulfur right over here
so i could write a big s
now the next thing we might want to
think about is the mass number of this
particular isotope remember an isotope
all sulfur atoms are going to have 16
protons but they might have different
numbers of neutrons so the sulfurs that
have different number of neutrons those
would be different isotopes so in this
case we have 16 protons
and we have 16 neutrons so if you add
the protons plus the neutrons together
you're going to get your mass number so
16 plus 16 is
32.
now let's figure out if there's going to
be any charge here
well the protons have a positive charge
the electrons have a negative charge if
you have an equal amount of protons and
electrons then you would have no charge
but in this case we have a surplus of
electrons we have two more electrons
than protons and so so we have a surplus
of the negative charged
particles
we
and we have two more we're going to have
a negative two charge and we would write
that as 2 minus so this is actually an
ion it has a charge so this is the
isotope of sulfur that has a mass number
of 32 the protons plus the neutrons are
32 and it has two more electrons than
protons which gives it this negative
charge let's do another example where we
go the other way
where we are told
we are given
some information about what isotope and
really what ion we're dealing with
because this has a negative charge and
then we need to figure out the protons
electrons and neutrons
well the first thing that i would say is
well look they tell us that this is
fluorine as soon as you know what
element we're dealing with you know what
its atomic number is when you look at
the periodic table and you can figure
out the number of protons remember
atomic number is number of protons and
that's what defines the element that's
what makes this one fluorine so let's go
up to the our periodic table
and we see
fluorine right over here has an atomic
number of nine that means any fluorine
has nine protons
so let's scroll back down
so just because it is fluorine we know
we have nine protons
now what else can we figure out
well we know we have a negative charge
right here and this this is we could use
this as a negative one charge
and so we have one more electron than we
have protons and so since we have nine
protons we're going to have 10 electrons
and then finally how many neutrons well
remember the neutrons plus the protons
add up to give us this mass number so if
you have nine protons well how many
neutrons do you have to add to that to
get to 18 well you're going to have to
have 9 neutrons 9 plus 9 is 18.